babayka st. Louis videos a little great
shirt bro yo Theo Brennan got a new
debate club question for you this week
who's them TV couch watching movies land
or less as he can to myself which of
these two actors have the better
collection of films Will Ferrell
or Ben Stiller we're talking old school
versus Meet the Parents anchorman vs.
Tropic Thunder Road thing vs. done by I
got Gang Gang cuz cuz baby and that's
seem like one of the New Age horror
films kind of the way that they had yeah
that looked like Blair Witch - mm-hmm
look pretty dope if you ask me uh what's
he asking well he's an outdoorsman you
can see he's got a bike in the back his
bike helmet also also indoors man cuz a
bunch of comic stuff in the back you
know Will Ferrell or Ben Stiller movies
so you got let's go through a couple Ben
Stiller Meet the Parents Tropic
something about Mary Tropic Thunder
gable man
directed and wrote bronze uh oh
dodgeball Oh Ben ruins my things you'll
endure that what else oh you met Trey
Anastasio bio bio pic I know what else
he he's in a knot Along Came Polly yeah
pretty kid anything okay Polly now you
go through Will Ferrell guys last movies
are bombers but yeah a lot of frickin
bombs dude stepbrothers was good I would
go with Ben Stiller man for me Oh like
mass like overall yeah look at Ben
Stiller's career compared to Will
Ferrell's will feel how like
stepbrothers hitter anchorman
SNL we had well Ben Stiller show on
Comedy Central is huge but you can't
just SNL it's on a show we're start
about movies I think for some body of
work for movies yeah what is will filled
up like okay anchorman that president
Crashers the campaign stepbrothers
touting a campaign called a goodnights
Anya's
oh yeah the lander he still is in that
too though yeah he's the main guy so
that's a wash they're both in that that
dating move over Ben Stiller gets all
sweaty that time at the dance oh that's
good I'm gonna go with this teller I
know that's that's something out marry
then still are all day people gonna say
well feel but 84% welfare yeah yeah
that's that's these that's like that's
something it's easy it's like that's and
that's a perfect example of how
something's wrong with us I prize you
put those two when you really think it
out I do think it's Benson you give the
bottle your work now who do I think it's
probably funnier
I think it's Will Ferrell but who do I
think said a better probably your
overall decent movies where I'm actually
like watch didn't been like all this is
pretty this here's the other thing Ben
Stiller escape of denim denim era the on
Showtime wanna he want to us or was with
it you want to Emma for is it any good
haven't seen it it's amazing
is it really so dope yeah alright man
let's just you know you think will fair
over there yeah even though we just list
out all those movies he's wrong birdie
bro ah that but you say one movie that
but then it's the movie no interesting I
see I buy that to me too as grown up
with something about Mary's more
important than anchorman some about Mary
was I mean that's that's the movie they
should do something something about the
Marines and it's like all sneaky stories
about something I have a different man
in there that'd be cool and Will
Ferrell's in it and Ben Stiller yeah
there's something bout the Mohicans been
so has never had a movie like that
Sherlock Watson movie which was just a
[ __ ] encyclopedia brown Mitty that's
a serious movie though yeah not a comedy
that comes out movie but Ben stirs never
had to miss with comedy look guys looked
at it later to is definitely huge myth
yep and Joe Dirt 2 wasn't that great
even though if you say it's a David
Spade he does not he does not want to
hear that they should have left it alone
sure they directly why they want to have
you and Joe Dirt I have no idea I don't
know your dirt six dude you know I'm
saying heaven versus hell
Tim dirt and hearing it dude yeah
good Jo are Jose over yeah his separate
the Tim to me or damp dirt dirt damp
dirt tried to yeah dry dirt dirt
back up a broccolini
get your life together
I'm not touching